c'est à dire que ça part de là et ça
remonte très très haut en fait
savoir igor igor ça n'a rien à voir et
moi je trouve que c'est un style et yann
ya plein de gens qui adorent non mais on
aime ça mais toi mais robin vous voulez
ressembler de plus en plus ça
[Applaudissements]
franchement il ya etc non mais vous vous
avez fait des trucs à l'étranger chaque
les yeux
n'arrête frère ne me dis pas que tu as
pas fait les lèvres et un
soutien qui à la place de la bouchard
est un faux mais vous avez sonné mais
mathieu dit la vérité l'affairé n'avait
rien les frères tellabs bouge pas avec
son coma ce fait comme insectes et les
rues
et comment cette période ça bouge pas
non là ça bouge pas tabou la dafa
tricatel être rationnel frère est de mes
gosses mais arrête avec tes enfants tu
sais même pas où ils sont les emplois
à ta peau on fait un truc à moi bordel
pas à moi c'est juste un analphabète
c'est pas du tout
il est très beau comme un magazine je
peux vous faire une petite que cette
analyse c'est bon il a fait des méchants
film est celle de la vérité francis y
atteint du botox à
sa se plie pas très au fait du moteur du
tournoi du botox et pkoi tu mens mais je
vous dis aujourd'hui il a des faux seins
il a dit
on la mettait une pression de plus de
1500 pages
toutes les classes de la belle-mère
arrêter le [ __ ] même québec tu as des
as mon frère pas dire j'ai dorée les
bagues matin coeurs croisés prétexte
[Applaudissements]
à nous les vaches et d'après vaches et
la perla
vous avez vraiment envie de rigoler
c'est le seul mec qui sait à leurs yeux
il achète ses t-shirts et victoria
secret's
arrête de ses bouteilles moi ce que
j'aime je vous dis moi ce que j'aime
c'est la franchise ou redis j'ai refait
un truc je n'ai jamais rien car j'ai été
blessé dans le métier camille défendent
becs arrête un peu il a des packs citron
la place d'edel est ici
mais bon fou mais ces défauts on le sait
et on le sait que tout le monde le sait
dans l'essai mais vous aider fatah viré
pour ça
à défaut papa je le sais mais bâtiment
mais je m'en prends est un menteur
invétéré tout le monde le sait juste des
couettes lundi je fais une radio mais
elle a dit je fais une radio et on verra
qui c'est qui mêle radio rfm non une
radio de mon corps scanner de mon club
ou bien ce qui est dans mon corps est
d'accord c'est beau
c'est la sauce total veut
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
abaisser le soldat il parle mais ses
lèvres rouge après sa garde pas le son
et tu vois c'est la bougie rentrer c'est
un gardien décalage car est un peu c'est
pas grave c'est pas grave mais ça te va
très bien mais vous êtes c'est quoi les
inquiéter clémentine on va fermer la
foulée
jean mathieu savons alors nos voitures
du caillou toi qui connais est-ce qu'il
a refait quelque chose d non je pense
pas mais je connais pas médecin je
regarde ses lèvres sont normales célèbre
c'est normal il est magnifique et
d'imputabilité l'unl m deux jours après
le retrait de gaza ça c'est refaire il
garda ça sert fait pas les mêmes quand
même offert
ça se ressemble la raison des gaffes
attention non mais c'est vrai fais gaffe
d'un vaisseau chinois
comme toi tu as fait d'elle tafer du
botox toi aussi un tueur
a fait du botox est sûre il a pris
3 mais moi je te de rien quand je fais
les choses le dis je vous emmerde ces
médecins qui ont elles connu la peur de
rien et du routage et déjà fait des
choses là pas récemment il faut que j'y
retourne à l'elysée
c'est quoi cette émission c'est pas
les secrets beauté que je ne pas voyager
retrouver isabelle l'uac
[Applaudissements]
la
chaux-de-fonds non pas s'offrant la
barrette frère si wiggins gb à réparer
les choses et les données je crois que
je fais déjà je vais te planter
je fais déjà gauche que jusque là je
fais des choses mais je dis pas de quoi
parce que c'est des secrets beauté il ya
des choses sur le corps sur le machin et
ça ça me coûte trois temps d'une photo
que ça me coûte 3 dans le même temps les
choses la fel botox société pagani l'a
dit et sur
une avenue parce que l'histoire gauche
et de l'avenue